كمان عقدت في الرياضه ايضا قمه عربيه
صينيه وفي ختام القمه قال وزير الخارجيه
السعودي ان القمه العربيه الصينيه تعد
نقطه انطلاق جديده بين الدول العربيه
وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه واشدد في مؤتمر
صحفي على اهميه تعزيز علاقات الاستراتيجيه
بين الصين ودول الخليج
انطلاقه الشراكه
وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه لتحقيق التنميه
المشتركه
ودفعه قويه وتعزيز علاقات الصداقه الراسخه
التي تربط دول المنطقه بجمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه
شهاده القمه السعوديه الصينيه عقد جلسه
مباحثات بين القياده الرشيده حفظ البضاعه
وفخامه الرئيس الصيني ركزت على تعزيز
الشراكه التاريخيه والاستراتيجيه المتميزه
بين البلدين واستثمار امكاناتها السياسيه
والاقتصاديه في خدمه مصالحهما المشتركه